le mac mini est main on va le pousser
jusqu'au bout on va regarder les
performances en 8k on va regarder les
températures on va regarder les temps
d'export on va faire plein de choses et
on va lui en mettre dans les dents mais
méchamment mais ça les amis vous le
savez ça sera juste après l'intro
[Musique]
il salue légendaire des grands c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mon
corps je suis encore une fois ravi de
vous retrouver pour une nouvelle vidéo
il ya pas très longtemps j'ai fait un
test sur les nouveaux mac mini m
et c'était très surprenant ce qu'on
arrivait à faire avec un modèle aussi
entrée de gamme en fait l'avion est
plein de questions vous avez beaucoup
réagit donc je me suis dit qu'on allait
essayer de le pousser dans ses
retranchements pour voir un petit peu ce
qui se passe donc pour que vous sachiez
bien ce qui va se passer il s'agit du
mac mini m2 2020 c'est la version avec
256 go de disque dur et seulement 8
gigas de ram et on va faire un test de
montage avec des fichiers 8 ko parmi les
fichiers les plus gourmands qu'on peut
trouver sur le marché pour l'instant on
va travailler avec final cut qui est
optimisé pour les puces m 1 d'ailleurs
si vous vous intéressez à final cut ma
formation est toujours en promo le lien
est dans la description donc ces
résultats ne sont pas vraiment
comparables avec premières par exemple
qui n'est pas optimisé forcément les
résultats seront beaucoup moins bon avec
première au moment où j'enregistre cette
vidéo bien entendu tout le monde ne
travaille pas avec ce type de fichier et
l'idée c'est pas forcément de vous
encourager à utiliser ce type de fichier
c'est surtout pour voir jusqu'où il peut
aller est ce que je me dis c'est que ce
qu'il sera possible de faire avec ces
fichiers la cfi chez ubi cas est bien
avec la plupart des autres fichiers qui
vont être sur des résolutions moindre ça
passera sans problème parce qu'il ya eu
des tests avec des gens qui disaient que
ça chauffe énormément que ça marchait
pas si bien que ça donc moi j'ai voulu
vérifier par moi-même donc ces partis
direction
final cut on va donc se plonger un petit
peu dans ce workflow ou huit cas je vais
vous montrer exactement tout ce que vous
devez faire pour reproduire ce test si
vous voulez leur faire chez vous vous
allez voir c'est vraiment pas très
compliqué allez on y va
c'est partit alors la première chose à
faire pour utiliser des fichiers raid
durera de code sur final cut qui ne les
lis pas nativement c'est d'aller
télécharger leur aide
apple workflow install york est un petit
plugin qui pèse rien du tout sur la page
que je vous montre ici voilà vous
téléchargez la dernière c'est la version
17 faudra redémarrer l'ordinateur etc
mais ça va tout simplement vous
permettre de lire les fichiers raid dans
final cut sans aucun problème et je vous
mets le lien pour télécharger en
description du plugin prochaine étape on
va aller télécharger des semble de
fichiers huit cas toujours sur le site
de adam si on n'a pas tous une raide qui
fait de l'avicca à portée de main mais
c'est vraiment vraiment pour le thé
pour voir un petit peu ce que le mac
mini a dans le ventre on prend le crème
de la crème pour ça arrête nous propose
ici tout un tas de fichiers de la
monstre au de l'hélium de la gemini fin
bref des trucs de fou nous on va se
concentrer sur les fichiers huit cas on
va apprendre cela dont vous pouvez les
télécharger et comme vous pouvez voir ce
sont des défis chez qui dure quelques
secondes c'est très très lourd c'est
très très gros donc prévoyez un petit
peu de temps pour le téléchargement
quand même si vous n'avez pas une
connexion de ouf
une fois qu'on a installé le plugin pour
pouvoir lire les fichiers une fois qu'on
a téléchargé les fichiers
on va aller dans schengen voir ce que ça
donne tout simplement je précise que les
fichiers sont stockées dans le disque
dur interne qui est très très très
rapide on fera un peu plus tard dans la
vidéo un test sur un disque dur externe
pour voir si ça change quelque chose
alors j'ai importé mes fichiers j'ai
déjà commencé à travailler pour pouvoir
vous montrer
donc j'ai ici mes fichiers raid brut la
la j'ai rien appliquer tout ce que j'ai
mis au dessus est désactivé donc il me
lit juste les fichiers vous voyez que ça
passe quand même assez crème pour
l'instant mais on va essayer de pousser
un petit peu la bête dans ses
retranchements
sachant que vous voyez probablement des
saccades sur votre écran ça vient de mon
enregistrement d'écran qui ne choque pas
tout les frames forcément mais ici peux
me croire sur parole ça marche
impeccable c'est hyper fluide ça tourne
c'est de l'avicca voilà ça marche
impeccable ah et pour pas triché vous
voyez des petits pointillés ici je n'ai
pas activé le rendu en arrière-plan
le rendu en arrière-plan sur final cut
c'est un procédé qui fait que dès que
vous ne touchez pas votre souris dès
qu'il ya un petit temps en fait final
cut va calculer va créer des fichiers
optimisé pour ne pas avoir justement à
calculer pendant la lecture ça sera des
fichiers qui va uniquement lire et qu'il
aura pas besoin de calculer sa gelée
désactivé pour vraiment con et les
performances de calcul brute du mac mini
si jamais ses activés par défaut vous
fait un petit commandes option pour
afficher les préférences et ici vous
voyez que vous pouvez l'activer ou le
désactiver le rendu en arrière-plan
choisir de le démarrer plus ou moins
rapidement ça peut être très bien pour
des fichiers un peu lourd et des bécanes
qui ont un peu de mal à lire de manière
fluide les
les fichiers que vous leur donnez donc
jusqu'ici tout va bien il ya quand même
une petite chose qu'il faut que je vous
précise c'est que dans présentation ici
j'ai choisi meilleure performance ça
veut dire qu'il ne nie pas les fichiers
de la manière la plus qualitative
possible là je privilégie le fait
d'avoir une timeline fluide on va voir
ce qui se passe si je met en meilleure
qualité mais ça on le fera en dernier
d'abord on va lui donner un petit peu de
travail en plus donc je vais ici j'ai
appliqué un calque avec une lutte
voilà une lutte de look d'ailleurs je
propose des luttes le lien étant
description que j'ai créé et moi même et
qui sont vachement sympa et donc là on
va lancer la lutte est appliqué le rendu
n'a pas été fait donc ça va être du
calcul brute en balance ça reste fluide
il gère donc la gestion du fichier
huit cas plus en plus il n'y a pas de
drogue frais n'y a rien c'est voilà ça
marche ça marche que vous dire bon on
lui a mis une lutte c'est quand même
généralement assez gourmand ce qu'on va
faire ici c'est que j'ai ajouté un grain
de films en incrustation par dessus ça
c'est quelque chose qui est quand même
vachement gourmands aussi on va voir ce
que ça donne si on rajoute la lutte plus
le grain de films attention c'est parti
et là encore une fois lutte plus grands
films grain de films en 4k et bassa
pasqua c'est toujours aussi fluide
il ya toujours pas de drogue frame ça
passe nickel alors dernière chose on va
faire une manip qui ne sert strictement
à rien mais qui est gourmande en
ressources s'est ajoutée du fou
gaussien voilà ça va être très moche
mais on va bien voir on va mettre en
valeur sur ce plan ici la voilà donc je
rajoute du fou ça c'est quelque chose
qui est très gourmand calcul est ce
qu'il va y arriver
réponse tout de suite eh bien oui
toujours pas de drogue frame toujours
pas donc là ici on a une lutte
on a un grain de films on a un flou que
vous dire maintenant ce qu'on va faire
c'est que on va passer quand même parce
que on va arriver on va arriver à le
faire craquer un c'est obligé on va
masquer tout ça et cette fois ci je vais
revenir sur meilleure qualité là j'ai
quand même des doutes sur le fait que ça
passe ou pas honnêtement un meilleure
qualité en 8k on va voir
ah ben voilà voilà voilà la limite a été
atteinte
là on a vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de drops fragments meilleure
qualité mais honnêtement les fichiers
sont tellement défini que quand je me
mets en meilleure performance
franchement je vois pas de différence là
comme ça sur mon écran dans mon
visualiseur je vois pas de différence
entre la qualité des fichiers ont
meilleure performance est meilleure
qualité ça se voit sur de la 4k ça se
voit aussi encore plus sûr de la full hd
parce qu'on a quelque chose d'un peu
flou c'est pas très joli
là vraiment au final ça passe mais on a
réussi à le faire craquer donc tissé
l'accent et lutter sans grain de films
et sans effet la en meilleure qualité
c'est sûr qu'on pourra pas s'en sortir
on ne pourra pas y arriver alors juste
pour voir
je vais remettre meilleure qualité je
verrai afficher tous mes effets et on va
regarder du point de vue de la
température parce que ça c'est un truc
il ya une vidéo qui est sorti a pas très
longtemps d'une dune anglophones qui
disait qu'avec première et ça je veux
bien la croire parce que première n'est
pas optimisé on arrivait température
extraordinaire de 100° 100° sait pas ou
feint pour un processeur mais là j'ai un
petit utilitaire et on va lancer la
lecture et voir ce qui se passe là on
voit que
l'ordinateur le cpu est à 26 degrés que
l'ordinateur est grosso modo à 30 degrés
sachant que donc j'ai failli rich iott
qui tourne avec oeil à quicktime qui
enregistre écran plus par dessus
derrière donc on lance on est en
meilleure performance et niveau
température ça monte un petit peu le cpu
passe à 33 degrés 34 c'est quand même
assez font parce que c'est ça redescend
à 33,35 toujours 33
ouais ça chauffe pas quoi ça chauffe pas
au final donc c'est là qu'on voit quand
même que tu es vraiment optimisé et
encore une fois je remet pas du tout en
question
les tests de cette youtube buzz qui a
fait quasi fondre soi-disant son son mac
100 degrés c'est pas fondre mais voilà
on a eu un pic à 40 degrés voilà mais
grosso modo on est passé de 30 degrés à
36 degrés ce qui rien en fait sur un cpu
cela encore ça montre qu'une fois que
les applications sont optimisés c'est
assez incroyable même si voilà on n'a
pas pu le pousser à fond avec la
meilleure qualité tout ça enfin on
arrive quand même à gérer ce workflow de
manière quand même assez hallucinante et
sans création de proxy pendant ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va faire un petit
test d'export tout simplement pour voir
un petit peu ce que ça donne en terme de
temps donc là je rappelle qu'on a une
minute
grosso modo de fichiers huit cas on va
faire un export en 4k je vais lancer mon
chrono je pars du principe que j'ai
aucun intérêt à vous mentir et donc je
vais le lancer là je vais pas l'afficher
en direct et on fera un bond dans le
temps pour que je vous dise à combien de
temps ça a pris pour faire cette export
donc ici export fichiers master très
bien réglage on est en h 264
[Musique]
quatre minutes et 45 secondes environ
ce qui est franchement pas mal ce qui
est franchement pas mal pour des
fichiers de cette taille là j'ai
enregistré un petit peu au passage la
température du mac
vous avez vu que pendant l'export il est
monté en gros à un tout petit peu plus
de 40 degrés ce qui est ridicule
le ventilateur ne s'est pas déclenchée
enfin en tout cas il tourne apparemment
un petit peu tout le temps à une vitesse
très lente ce qui fait qu'on ne l'entend
pas mais il s'est pas mis à souffler
comme un porc notre dernier test
maintenant c'est de voir si si on
utilise un disque externe
est-ce que les performances sont les
mêmes j'ai déplacé ma bibliothèque
entière sur le disque là j'utilise un
samsung t7 donc est quand même très
rapide c'est la technologie nvm le cd
débit d'environ 1 gigabits seconde donc
très rapide pas autant que le disque
interne du match donc ce qu'on va voir
pour le coup ici c est ce que c'est
intéressant d'acheter de l'espace disque
directement dans le mac ou vu que c'est
un mac mini fixe d'acheter un disque dur
à côté qui sera moins cher est-ce que
les performances seront meilleurs sur le
mac mini que sur le disque dur externe
on va voir ça tout de suite je les
ouverte à partir du disque maintenant on
va voir tout simplement ce que ça donne
juste en lecture ici et ça nous donnera
un aperçu soit ça marche et auquel cas
ça veut dire que les performances sont
inchangées soit ça ne marche pas et j'ai
des lags et des drops frame et là on
pourra se dire que ça vaudra le coup
d'acheter du stockage interne chez apple
voilà ce que ça donne tout de suite
voilà pas de drops frame que ce soit sur
le disque externe ou sur le mac mini
dont vous n'achetez pas le stockage qui
coûte une blinde chez apple
achetez vous un petit nvm eux comme ce
samsung t7 et vous verrez vous pourrez
faire les choses exactement de la même
façon
donc maintenant je vais vous dire un
petit peu ce que j'en conclus moins de
tout ça m'a déjà ça confirme ce que je
pensais déjà c'était d'accès une machine
qui est très intéressante en termes de
puissance et surtout le rapport
consommation d'énergie puissance ça
montre aussi que l'optimisation dès
applications est vraiment quelque chose
de primordial et il faut espérer que le
plus possible d'application de plugins
et autres outils vont arriver
rapidement parce que pour l'instant les
utilisateurs de première ne peuvent
absolument pas reproduire ce genre de
test ça sera impossible la bécane va
vraiment vraiment vraiment galéré enfin
même si ce mac mini est une très très
bonne machine
il ya quand même des rumeurs comme quoi
dans l'année à venir il va y avoir des
choses encore plus hallucinante qui vont
sortir ça reste une machine d'entrée de
gamme donc si vous envisagez d'acheter
cette machine réfléchissez bien
potentiellement il ya peut-être des
choses qui seront sûrement un peu plus
cher mais plus puissante qui vont
arriver par la suite
mais quand même franchement je suis
bluffé c'est c à c ur si d'ailleurs vous
aussi vous êtes bluffé bien mettez le
petit coup de blaster sur le pouce en
l'air qui se situe juste en dessous de
cette vidéo pouvait aussi aller voir
pleins d'autres vidéos que j'ai fait sur
la chaîne je suis sûr que ça va vous
intéressez vous abonner soyons fous et
puis moi je vous dis les amis à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
voilà la raison de la casquette depuis
depuis quelques temps j'ai attendu que
ça repousse un petit peu histoire de pas
non plus montré un crâne d'oeuf mais
voilà c'était le petit cadeau de la fin